the girag an experience so what when you
look at that situation the casino
situation where now all the sudden
economically these tribes can thrive and
the the reservation that owns that
casino can thrive and as you're saying
the money goes straight back to the
reservation and to the people that run
it and and it it legitimately helps the
people that live on that reservation
correct absolutely
what other things like that can be done
to also take advantage of the fact that
there are sovereign nation and allow
them to economically thrive without
things like fracking and [ __ ] that's bad
for the environment are there other
things that are being implemented that
could also help oh yeah absolutely there
are all different types of economic
development going on in Indian country
that can be very successful for external
businesses too because there are certain
benefits that an outside business would
get if they did for example
manufacturing within Indian country they
could benefit from certain tax
exemptions and and and and rebates that
they wouldn't get in in a state so if if
if corporations would would go into
Indian country instead of you know going
across the border or going somewhere
else there would be great opportunities
but and some tribes are taking advantage
of those business opportunities not just
gaming but out of gaming has grown a lot
of a lot of investment a lot of
entrepreneurial ship in tribes and a lot
of the money has gone back to help
educate and teach language and bring
items back that are religious items and
in ancestors and and the things that are
important for that tribal nation so
there's many different ways of
investment
and that that tribal nations look at it
it's not necessarily economic but it's
about healing their people and and
helping us survive and live better than
we have in the past so investment takes
many forms in Indian country
[Applause]